la querelle de l'enseignement privé
durci le climat politique en cette fin
de semaine dimanche aversa et les
partisans de l'enseignement libre ont
l'intention de prouver leur force et
leur détermination les élus de
l'opposition ils seront nombreux
le président du rpr jacques chirac en
tête répondant aux voeux du chef de
l'état qui a fait savoir son souci de
calmer le jeu
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
alain savary dans un entretien au monde
affirme que les positions des
protagonistes des négociations se sont
rapprochés mais pas au point d'attendre
d'atteindre pardon un consensus minimal
de son côté l'archevêque de paris
monseigneur lustiger dans un entretien à
la croix et ce matin sur europe1 prêche
la réconciliation il a lancé un appel
aux responsables politiques avant de
s'adresser dimanche au défenseur du
privé dans le camp des laïcs aussi la
tension monte et le secrétaire général
du comité d'action laïque s'adresse à
son tour à monseigneur lustiger
j'entends chaque jour proclamé que les
manifestations en cours ne sont dirigés
ni contre le gouvernement ni contre
l'école publique
j'ai une proposition très précise à
faire il ya quelques jours monsieur
chirac a fait une déclaration blessante
humiliante et est dangereuse dans ses
effets à savoir il s'agit d'une mainmise
sur les cerveaux de nos enfants c'est
une attaque et on t contre l'école
publique qui décolle de tous les
français
avant 6 ans lustiger qui s'adressera
dimanche à versailles à la foule et à
monsieur chirac y sera présent doit à
mon sens condamné formellement
explicitement et clairement cette
intervention de monsieur chirac je
serais pour ma part très attentif à la
réponse à cette question et s'il
condamne l'intervention de monsieur
chirac coffret vous en excuses on
prendrait acte avec le plus grand
intérêt parce que cela signifiera cela
signifierait que les évêques sont
décidés à ne pas servir d'alibi à la
droite politique jusqu'à plus ample
informé c'est à cela qu'il sert en
faisant ça ne politisent itou par les
affaires précisément je demande à
monsieur à monseigneur lustiger de la
dépolitiser cet appel traduit bien la
crainte du secrétaire général du cnal
michel bouchard est sage de voir le
débat
s'il reste sur le terrain politique
tourné au désavantage des laïcs mais par
ailleurs les défenseurs de l'école
publique reste ferme sur le fond en
recul du gouvernement
un refus de régler ce problème serait
effectivement sujet accompli fermeté
donc mais aussi inquiétudes chez les
enseignants de l'école publique qui
s'estime victime d'une campagne
calomnieuse de la part de l'enseignement
catholique
c'est profondément choqué par la lutte
française campagne c'est une espèce de
mobilisation contre l'école contre ces
méthodes
la fiche qui est utilisé pour appeler à
cette mobilisation représente une prison
derrière laquelle les enfants semblent
de retenue je trouve que l'on va trop
loin dans la polémique les m insulter
ils sont accusés de vouloir sa
qu'appareil fonds former les esprits des
enfants ce qui est profondément chaud
mais pour l'heure dans le camp laïc pas
question de mobilisation visiblement on
attend les déclarations du gouvernement
avant de prendre des décisions y est
aussi chez les catholiques des partisans
de l'enseignement public comme le prouve
la pétition lancée par témoignage
chrétien pétition qui a recueilli plus
de 13 mille signatures les états majors
politiques préparent activement les